And crazy.
You don't want to be here.
You want to be in the mountains in
Montana now you taught him in Colorado
anymore.
It's too many fucking momos
and got no fucking money.
Came into fake fucking money and
bought the hillbillies out the real
motherfuckers that you
needed it in case shit.
Gotta go like Woody Creek
to find those people.
You got to know Woody Creek.
Is that still fucking ham?
It's just once you're
fucking booze is up there,
you can really,
you got to go deep,
deep in the mountains of
Gunnison and shit like that.
You find those cracks.
Gunnison,
Brian,
you got your volume on.
We're echoing Gudnason
Gudnason where's that?
That's down south.
What do you think about all that
shit about the Denver airport?
Do you know anything about the conspiracy
behind the Denver airport is the
Denver airport.
First of all,
they moved way more dirt than
needed to and so there's this,
all this thought that there's some sort
of subterranean tunnel tunnel system and
it's all based on the end of the world.
Like shelters.
They fucked up.
Stapled to that point was a brilliant,
what it was like Burbank,
you could smuggle a fucking
dead fucking key coconut.
Nobody said nothing.
And all of a sudden they
came up with a bright idea.
Let's fucking make an airport
90 miles farther out by Kansas.
So when it snows,
we really get fucking buried.
We have no protection.
That's a bunch of cowboys,
Bro.
Making decisions.
And then trust me,
they're too stupid to,
even though the conspiracy
theory is they had an array,
but the people that built it may be,
but if the government was
really truly behind it,
like all these people think what it is,
is that they made an airport there.
But in constructing the airport,
they also built some sort of underground
safeguard oh three strongest stance.
So there's gotta be some Kinky Shit.
Well,
you know,
if it's close,
I mean that would be a move,
right?
No hills in the airport and
then build some shelters.
I mean,
that airport is bike fucking Kansas.
When you go on to the
Kansas during dick out,
that's what they call it.
The hip was,
it was easy,
man.
When I lived in Denver or in boulder,
rather,
it was easy to drive there.
How far was the drive?
Fucking hour.
Nothing.
Never any traffic.
It'd be 25 minutes.
Here's the deal though,
bro.
There's no traffic out that don't matter.
It used to be 25 minutes with
no traffic on fucking tones.
Crack the window a little bit.
They built this monster to spend money.
Yeah.
They built this bond,
this monster to to,
to just,
you know,
like when I went to fucking
Newark to see the fight with you,
Dave,
we did Newark.
They built a soccer stadium and soccer
stadium in Newark that spending money
left and right,
but they still can't put in
a left hand turning signal.
So if you've got to make a left 29
fucking miles and people got a male,
they're trying to keep up their reputation
as the car Jack Capitol of the world.
And if felt like some left turn signals,
you've got some outlet people can escape,
can escape the drama.
Fucking amazed.
That's the thing about that.
It's like,
you know,
they think that's a,
there's something really going
on inside that Denver airport.
There's all these documentaries,
um,
dedicated to it.
And one of the reasons for it is because,
um,
there's a,
these crazy murals that they're painted
up in the Denver airport and they're
really disturbing man.
Their apocalyptic,
like one guy's got a fucking gas mask
on with a giant sword and there's like
pictures of children and coffins
and there's fire in the background.
Have you
ever seen that shit?
Yeah,
but yeah,
we've actually talked about
it on this podcast before we,
yeah.
But do you think that
has anything to do with,
with that thinking you
putting the two together?
I don't think that it does,
definitely,
but it's interesting,
you know,
I mean,
I don't have opinion one way or another.
I've listened to the people talk about
how it's some great escape base and that
2012 there's going to be,
you know,
fucking asteroid's gonna
hit that they're tracking,
it's going to kill everybody except
the people that are in this underground
bunker.
I don't know,
man.
I watched a TV show on those dudes,
those dudes that have,
uh,
they've,
they've bought like fucking condos out
in these shelters out in like death
valley and Shit.
Have you seen those people have space
in death valley and so they have like a
condo inside this
underground bunker thing.
It's out in the middle of fucking nowhere.
You have to drive.
And he'd go out there
and they had these shows,
I forgot who was the host of the show,
but they,
they took you on a tour of these
fucking but might've been Jesse Ventura.
No,
it wasn't him because
they had a sense of humor.
But the,
whoever it was was like really?
And they,
they take it in his fucking tour of these
underground bunkers that they have set
up where they can survive
a fucking nuclear bomb.
I mean,
these guys are like half a
mile deep in the fucking earth.
So you survived the bump.
Now what shoe and eight fucking Momo
Vena assholes looking at each other.
Listen,
just live your fucking life.
These people at big into that shit
and just live your fucking life.
And we get hit by a bomb.
The best thing you could do is move on
to the fucking next life and pray to God.
It'll be fucking better doors.
Music.
What the fuck is wrong with me?
I'm going to live in a fucking
imagine being live in your life.
Consumer.
What happened?
One's a bomb drops after
[inaudible] 60 those people,
that shit wore off in the 60s they all
moved into buildings but underground
drops with little fucking sandwiches.
That's how Tang was
fucking and ventilating.
Then bent the Tang for.
So when we go in that fucking total
of doom and went after the Russians,
fuck everybody in the ass.
We come out and where we've got
vitamin C from the fucking tank,
not a tank was in basketball,
but guess what?
Our is aren't the Russians anymore.
It's a lot bigger than that and
whenever it's going to hit now,
right now there's a thing going on in
Japan where we don't fucking know they
align until the people
just like everything else.
They're lying a 20 mile radius.
That shit's horrible.
That shit is horrible.
Radiation is fucking horrible and the
best is all these people are raising their
hands up.
We have radiation in key west.
Don't blame it on fucking Japan.
Don't blame it on Japan now.
That's not your pants for you guys.
Vet Radiation on your own.
You're greasing motherfuckers down
there off the coast of Florida.
You filthy cock suckers.
You going to blame on
the full fucking Japs.
They're walking around with
fucking masking as radiation.
West Florida that's primarily hooked up
horse riding guys off and creating heat
burning that they put in the
fucking beach during CSI Miami.
They see all these chicks Brazilian
jumping up and down with that ass.
That's what that fucking is.
Pussy Buck,
a nasty radiation,
but it's something extra dirty of
a point that you get from Miami.
You ever watched porn from Miami
because it's almost like they're like a
retarded people fucking,
you know what I mean?
And they're oiled up,
oil dropping and just something
about it like you can't relate.
It's hard to even jerk off
trouble with Joe Rogan.
None of mine.
The martians and lift going
up in fucking trouble.
This thing in Japan is a lot
worse than what they're saying.
You think so?
Fuck yeah.
What makes you say this?
I just know our society and
they don't want to scare us,
which was fucking Japanese started coming
out with six flock and eyes and shit.
You don't know which
one is looking at you.
Then they're going to say one
better so he could see better.
Maybe,
you know,
maybe that's 2012 they,
that'll be the next mutation.
Good Dab action to radiation.
This is not fun.
Any animals besides roaches that
are really good with radiation?
Roaches is supposed to be the best at it,
right?
Yeah,
slip the right thing.
But is that,
is that even,
is that even just like a wives' tale?
I don't know.
Someone should do us a favor and now
we know that the Japan is fuck sandbox
cockroaches over there
with a Webcam on it.
Let's see what's up.
If you love America,
I go over there
you that stupid fucking water,
all that soil and I don't know what
the fuck's going on and you know what?
Now besides that,
we're all spread out live view.
Where in this fucking place,
what the fuck
are you?
Fucking crazy.
These guys are just sitting there waiting.
It's like,
uh,
it's like,
you're just waiting for us to wear
out before you fuck us in their home.
But what's that guy would've
been looking for for 11 years?
He's just sitting there going all,
we got them now.
This went out like motherfuckers
would just light a fire in Kansas,
CNN,
breaking news.
I get CNN breaking news sent to my phone.
Holla US intelligence source.
CIA is operating inside Libya to help
us increase military and political
understanding what that means.
Somebody is about to get jet bitch whore.
Shit quote is that,
oh,
this CIA is there to increase the
military and political understanding.
No,
this is what we want you to do.
Do you understand?
Okay,
here's the political understanding.
We got the bombs bitch.
Okay,
we got fucking robots that
we can operate from Nevada.
Okay?
And you don't even see them because they
blend in with the sky and they don't
make any noise because they're fucking
solar powered and they can can contain
hell fire missiles.
Hell fire.
That's what I decided to name him.
Not,
you know,
the,
the beautiful flower missile or you know,
Lick my ass hole missile,
no.
Hell Fire Hellfire missiles and they're
shooting them from another fucking part
of the world.
Imagine a lag they have.
They must have to real like
plan a shot in advance.
Like it just like playing
quake online when you got lag.
If you have like a 56 k connection and
there's some asshole you're planning has
got a cable modem and you know,
he gets to move quicker than you because
his downtime is pink time between
connecting to the server
and back as much quicker.
So you're a fuck.
These guys must have like super lag.
1985 we went to see ran both to when
that motherfucker took an hour out,
when the explosive at the end
and when he shot at all of his,
lost our money.
Nobody liked the black people.
Black people love our
rules and explosives it.
I seen that movie that has 78th street.
I never seen black
people crazy in my life.
When Rambo came out of the mud
on his eyes opened up and choked.
Her mother thought black
people went bananas.
They're like yelling.
We should've thought of that,
but what is it about black
dudes that love martial arts?
Love it.
They love anything special.
I got dude doing some crazy shit like,
oh,
that motherfucker got a gun in the shoe.
Check that shit out
because something about it.
Dude pulls his shoe off and
guns down the bad guy like,
oh shit.
No,
he didn't.
What does that,
what does it mean?
They're just very vocal.
They're excited.
Thing about this was,
that was 20 years ago.
The shit we got now as bombs
and stuff is off the charts.
We got a bond that comes at you as a car
that follows you to the gas station pro
or you're pumping gas.
It turns into Obama.
Guy Pops on,
taps you on the shoulder and says goodbye.
That's the shit we got.
We got shit that comes to your house.
Just looked like a cake.
Happy Birthday and when you're
going to block the candles,
it's just fucking blows up.
We got some shit now.
You know what?
I saw that it was really crazy.
They got this rover,
this a,
this a remote controlled drone rover
that's moving around that can jump in the
air.
It gets up to a fence and I think you
can go like eight or nine feet in the
fucking air and it moves up to the fence
and then it just goes and flies to the
end.
Landsdale the side and it looks like
basically it's like like some sort of a
flat box,
you know where all the electronics is
with like two tractor to rubber tractor
things on the side of it I guess.
And the fucking thing
flies through the air.
I mean,
what's,
what's next?
You know,
that's the other thing that
people are thinking about.
A lot of the shit that's
going down in Afghanistan.
A lot of the shit that's going down in
the Middle East period and said the CIA
has got all kinds of shit going on.
All kinds of little tiny
little drones and explosives.
It blowing up in convenient
spots of spark action.
You know,
that's what they'd do.
They,
that's what they do is bark war and get,
you know,
they've always done that.
But the bottom line of this,
what do you,
what do you think is really going on?
They figured out some Libyan doctor
figuring out a way how to grow 50 kilos of
heroin in your bath tub
in the United States.
Find out and that Jack,
that motherfucker Kadafi,
he's got an army of motherfuckers around
this guy with missiles and explosives,
but the United States is Jacqueline.
This guy's got something to do with age.
It's got something to do with fucking
why we're over there in the fucking first
place.
The whole nucleus of this thing.
People are dying in Detroit from heroin.
It was fucking war and we're still,
now we're going to take
over Libya boxes or money,
Bro.
Isn't it amazing how many people would
think you're crazy when you start talking
about the fact they're in
Afghanistan for heroin,
people going to,
what are you talking about?
They'll look at you like you just
fucking just ate a bowl of shit.
They'll looky,
looky.
Oh,
you're ready?
[inaudible] person who,
yeah,
we're at war for heroin.
Where do you think that money's going,
man?
What?
Do you know how much money
you were talking about?
They can ignore that.
You're fucking crazy.
We want to take over a country
so we get a better gyros.
That's what you tell him that we've
taken over a consciously because I don't
know what that fucking loot dog,
that's the bottom line.
Bottom line.
There's all sorts of lewd over there.
Yeah,
and this is all sorts of Luton.
Libya too.
I mean it's,
it's,
is it a fucking coincidence
that for whatever reason
we decide to attack instead
of going to Mexico and straighten out
that bullshit that's right next door.
But on Mexico's guns,
Burritos,
burritos and hookers
and donkeys and Tequila,
because there's not a
lot of shit to offer.
Mexicans got ready though.
Getting,
but listen,
that's some crazy
motherfuckers don't end well.
They gotta.
They gotta clean up their problem.
They've got a big problem and
it's because of the United States.
It's a big part of it.
They wanted to make everything legal.
They wanted to,
you know they did.
Do you know that?
They you,
here's a little known fact.
Mexico has decriminalized everything,
small amounts.
When you're not selling it,
everything's legal.
Now.
You could get acid in Mexico,
you can get mushrooms in Mexico.
They did decriminalize everything just
because they had to allocate resources to
fight in these fucking drug lords.
I mean that's a,
that's a gone country.
That country is gone.
The country doesn't have
a government anymore.
That's right next door,
right next door.
Right next door.
The fucking drug army is,
it's like going to war with
someone who lives in your country.
It's like if we were fighting al Qaeda,
but al Qaeda had billions of dollars
and it was way more armed and they were
living here.
That's what it's like.
That's what it's like being
a fucking comes in Mexico.
Here's the crazy thing.
Mexico is coming back to get,
what's this bitch,
California and Texas rock though.
You can't take Texas.
You can't take care of even the Mexicans
will the go around Texas and Jack
Wyoming though Jack Dallas,
Dallas,
uh,
tie our candidate shit.
They'll give them a beat.
Nah,
you can to the outskirts of Texas.
They'll come out of their hunting
blinds and kill you is all,
I don't have a chance here.
He lives there.
Ted Nugent lives in Waco now.
Yeah.
You can't fuck with text.
He does.
He's got a high fence.
I've always admired what
I think he's a retard,
but I think he does a lot of
things that I really agree with.
And one of the things that I agree
with is when he lived in Michigan,
he had this bad ass compound.
We let 2000 acres or something like that
and it was all fenced in and he had all
these animals living inside his compound
and he would just go and Jack Him and
that's where he got all this food from.
He got all his food from hunting
on his own property and I'm like,
God damn it.
That's fucking brilliant.
That's how I want to live.
I would love to live like that.
Just eat what you hunt.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why
I was into moving to Colorado.
One of the reasons why I was up there,
I was like,
look,
if the shit hits the fan,
you're living in the woods.
You know there's a lot of animals
out here in the spring water,
the compaction,
fucking shooting a pig.
It in a fucking cave.
What your kids have cave.
Oof.
Just given him all fucking civil way and
living in a tent with fucking eaters.
If this shit ever went down and got Kinky,
can you imagine that Kinky,
kinky shit gets kinky
dog and the fuck this.
So I'm excited about Oregon.
Oregon's one of those,
so we're going to have
a good fucking time.
Oregon's one of those states
has been under grid for years,
but no,
getting a little bud.
They kept it hush hush.
I used to get some good,
we'd love to get 15 fucking years ago.
It's bass,
Ashlyn,
Eugene Bend,
Oregon's a Hippie flubbing
foundation over there and,
but Portland's a pretty hippie place too,
isn't very hippy now he's up
to at girls have dirty feet.
They have dirty feet.
Make them put socks on,
fuck socks and say sign and
dump breathing my mouth.
Portland was the place that I went to
last year and we were at trying to find
the most person in a Costco
for like a half hour meeting.
The girl is with Amy cannot,
who'd you fuck?
Yeah.
And we couldn't find anyone.
So Costco though,
dude,
go to a Costco in Burbank and even
with a bunch of cripples there too.
I know,
but that's a pack Dasko I
usually watch time one string.
You need to go to better places.
So it was a smaller amount.
Smaller amount of people
you'd want to fuck.
That's okay dude.
You're going to go,
I'll be okay.
Got to live somewhere with this.
If this place falls apart.
I went to this too many humans here.
Too many.
We keep on saying that,
but we're not doing anything about it.
I did.
I fucking moved,
man.
The only reason why I came back cause
Mrs. Reagan got pregnant and because the
dog had eaten by mountain,
if it wasn't for that,
went to the suburbs then or stuff.
That's my next move.
Almost not like I'm already
talking to real estate agents.
Oh
she'll let you talk [inaudible] Beck.
But the move to move is you go and he'd
get a summer place and you try it out
and lived there for a summer.
That's right.
You'd be super nice while you're there.
So it becomes on the [inaudible] just
every time we're there I'll just bring
home flowers and shit and then we come
back to la and then it's all Jujitsu and
loud music and too much pot smoke.
Yeah,
daddy's crazy in la.
Daddy just wants to fight and smoke
pot and he's walking around naked.
No,
in Colorado.
Daddy wants to go get ice cream
and daddy's bringing flowers home.
See you just train them.
Brown got blowing farts on her.
Here's the problem.
Joe Rogan,
Scott,
Joe Rogan's got a great
wife and Joe Rogan.
I went to his home last week and that
was one of the first times Mrs Rogan was
home and a couple of times,
and I'd been up there like four times.
This is Roldan likes to rock the house
and the quantum was up where you live now.
All you gotta do is go
down and who she'd get,
the party started where you
put it before motherfuckers.
That's a witness relocation play.
She had to drive 90 miles before she even
seen a daddy's girl who was another 20
miles.
She was from all the weapon boulder,
the first mall that she cares
about his cherry fucking creek.
You know what I'm saying?
So you had a two foils at Denver?
Yeah.
Was groups out away from the more
you got to keep a closer to the wall,
you had a 90 fucking miles dog.
I slipped on the almost blew up.
What am I loved the most living up there.
That was that.
There was a small amount of people,
man,
smaller boulders only got a
hundred thousand plus people.
Not that much man.
And people are friendly.
I like that there's a more relaxed vibe.
And I think that shit is healthy.
I think there's something exciting
about living in a big city,
especially if you're,
you know,
you're involved in the hustle and
bustle and you're really trying to make
something happen and you know,
it's like,
I dunno,
but Casey,
that New York are real.
It's a really good,
if you got the voice,
you probably get married
again after a week.
You dumb fuck.
Talking to a real rogue is
going to shut that far yet.
You've got to figure out a way to get
a fucking coffee hut to the mall of
America where the action is.
Any of that.
Don't worry about it.
Then you've got to move a little closer.
That was too much
and he just needed to move to Texas.
Texas is cool.
This is the answer.
I like Austin.
I'm a big fan of that.
Austin,
Texas.
I'll tell you that.
I'd lived there if I was going to live,
but more lane is not legal there.
The thing about Colorado is
it's just like California.
You could just go rockweed everywhere
and people will move to Austin.
No,
no,
not yet.
Not yet.
The shit hits the fan.
Anything can happen.
You know,
when,
when the shit hits the fan and everybody
gets scared and then you start making,
you know,
survival choices.
You can live in Kansas,
you know,
and you'd rather be healthy in Kansas,
you know?
But,
um,
uh,
the wheat stores in Colorado
are just like out here,
Bro.
It's just how they're everywhere.
There's one place in Denver where
there's fucking seven of them on a street
there.
Every way easier to get
a license though to same,
same deal.
I get headaches.
Okay.
Bang prescription.
So I didn't know.
It was like,
I don't want you to Adam 20 minutes
away from me when I was shooting it and
we'll be like,
yeah,
Nice.
Like a doc.
Oh yeah.
There's a place that I used
to go to in the mountains.
It was like a gift shop and they were
doing do it struggling and they were doing
terrible and you know,
the fucking,
they were about to lose their business
and then they started selling weed in the
back of the gift shop legal.
They've got a legal license.
Boom.
Now they're balling.
Now they're,
they're about to open.
Their one place they opened
up in boulder is supposedly,
I don't know if it's open yet,
but they were talking about it was
going to be 30,000 square feet.
It was going to be three floors.
I don't know if they went through with it.
I need to find out if they did because
that's just the most ridiculous shit I've
ever heard.
That's a Goddamn shopping and the
Walmart of weed now Walmart of weed,
but they had great spots there,
man.
They had great spots.
We can get weed.
I got some no problem.
We two days ago in Hollywood,
it's 31% THC level.
You'll leave.
This shit ain't even necessary,
but again,
it's Matt.
I've been smoking Matt since 2006 and
you got to figure that every year it gets
a little stroller.
It's dead straight week.
They pave his girl.
I forgot to bring up,
but it looks like one of the
Martians from Independence Day.
You can see the sativa and
indica grown around it.
It's like a hybrid.
What if I tell you I heard
my joint over that right now.
Are we give it to you now?
I went and got it.
No you didn't.
Yeah,
I didn't go get that shit.
What's it called?
Mac Number one.
Oh Gee.
Oh that shit is fucking strong.
I had to go to the gym.
Was fucked up though.
Sounds good.
Dog slide or are we going?
Is going to be front.
Last time we didn't have,
all the time I went to Eugene,
Oregon with Jody Ferdy and we had a
Saturday night then for a one night if a
Tribble but it was the same night that
there was a convention for like the
Oregon Association of retarded children.
I don't want to say it wrong,
but it was like the children that Special
Olympics and they had a lot of little
retire.
The kids run around so
when I got to check in,
I'm high as a motherfucking.
There's all these kids with
balloons and I'm just freaking,
cause Oregon got some beep week.
Know what I'm saying?
That's him at the gas station.
Brian,
he's going to love this shit.
So I got a lighter,
we check into the hotel
in Eugene and the Joe.
This is not 10 or 15 of them.
This is 600 children,
you know,
Special Olympics,
200 retarded ones and that parents,
well,
so I go to my room,
you know we small,
we do the show.
The show is in the hotel,
but on a different part,
they're having a little dance.
You had to see this.
They were all holding hands,
a little balloons
and the disco and it was very cute to see.
But if a lot with the story,
a lot of people don't
know is retarded guys.
Boys are the strongest motherfuckers in
the world and that most of the verdict
really y'all?
I've heard that it,
boy,
they go fucking nuts.
Have you seen them?
If you show them your pussy.
So listen to me.
We're in the fucking
comedy club in Austin.
They switch it at 10 o'clock they
switched it and turn it into a disco
and Jody's got a couple of cocktails
in it and she started dancing.
She got the big until he's at the time,
and there's this little retarded boy who
breaks away from the fucking pile and
goes into the dance and he starts to
look at Jodi and you could see Joe Rogan
and he's losing his fucking mouth now.
And finally he goes,
don't want to dance with
starts dancing with,
right.
He started to answer it.
Then he starts crying.
They wouldn't.
Jodie thinks it's cute and
all of a sudden they come in,
they're like,
hey,
he is this little David,
and they come to grab him and David
fucking snapped like one of those fucking
gorillas in the zoo right now.
They had three black doorman that we're
trying to tackle a little Timmy little.
Timmy was drawn them around like Brock
Lesnar thrown around fucking John Fitch.
Just pick the whole
offensive line of the giants.
Couldn't help his little retired down
three fucking black gorillas and he's
just,
and Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee.
I'm not,
no,
no.
She knows tennies.
He went fucking ape shit.
He's pushing them.
The counters came.
They had to throw him on the
fucking floor and put his hand.
Oh no
pennies.
He was fucking ape shit dog.
Wow.
Those little cards go fucking bananas
when you show him this little what cars
and it was just teddy.
Can you imagine if it was
the monkey who went to jail,
Bro,
he's visit University of Eugene.
These are big black football players.
They couldn't control
this little 12 year old.
He was banging them,
throwing them around like 1212 or 13
just throwing these fucking black guys
around and said,
I'd never forget that.
That they had to put him on the floor,
handcuff him,
shoot him.
Tranquilize him.
This little fucking poor kids seem
teddies and he went fucking bananas.
Bananas.
That's crazy.
I wonder if they're just doing
what everybody wants to do,
but just doesn't have the ball.
They ha they don't have the walls.
That's a breakdown.
You know what I mean?
Wonder if that's what people
like instinctively want to do.
I think like,
yeah,
it retards can't be like extra,
more horny right now.
Probably not extra horny.
It's that fan on them.
Sweat light.
Joe Rogan's house went,
not the electricity.
You know what I'm saying?
You're killing me here.
Ooh Bro.
This kid went fucking bananas.
He ripped that Sherry,
cause you can't even beat them up.
What do you,
what do you do?
Do you,
you can't drop a bomb on it.
Funny thing was that they built like a
wall at first and they throw them out
first.
They asked me to leave and
he was like the building,
two black guys got shoulder to shoulder
and he was grappling their shoulders.
Mm hmm.
I mean it was fucking scary.
No,
don't know.
They look bad.
You know?
That's one of the weird things about
people that are retarded or down syndrome
or whatever.
They don't seem to know.
You know,
they just kind of are,
they just behaved.
They don't,
they're like,
good,
what am I into?
A book is mom and they're not like that.
They just themselves.
Right.
You know what
I mean?
It's like that must be a strange,
strange existence where,
you know,
that's part of being dumb is that
you're too dumb to realize you're dumb.
You know?
And I'm not saying dumb,
like there's like they're lazy.
Like they have an issue,
there's a mental issues and the mental
imbalance or whatever the fuck it is.
But I mean,
they're,
they're impaired,
but there's so impaired,
they don't know they're impaired.
Like they've lost the ability
to see that they're impaired.
You know,
what a strange thing,
what if they all have it in her
voice that that's completely normal.
Like,
but they can't take a to be like,
you know,
you know what I mean?
So the whole time there's this,
like,
I can't believe how much they
treat me so horrible and I wish I,
you know,
but they can't,
when they tried to say it,
it's like we're married for them.
Well,
there's probably,
there's probably a lot of that.
Yeah.
I think there's a bunch
of different types of,
you know,
being fucked up.
Right.
You know,
for sure there's that too.
it's not,
it's not just simple as,
yeah.
There's some,
there's varying degrees.
Yeah.
There's varying degrees
along the way that are,
you know,
I mean,
it's fucking crazy thing,
man,
to,
to have your mind impaired.
You know and look,
look,
our minds are impaired in comparison.
I was watching this fucking 12 year old
kid is autistic kid with 170 Iq doing
his take on the theory of relativity
and he's writing out equations on this
fucking window and I'm watching this kid.
I'm like,
this kid might as well be a fucking alien.
All right,
I don't know what he's doing.
I have no idea.
He's explained this
like this is all simple,
simple shit.
When this is so far
beyond my capacity to him,
to this artistic kid,
I am retarded.
Okay?
I am this guy who he has to humor because
I can't understand a fucking word,
a letter,
a singular part of his equation.
I don't know what's going on up there.
It's chaos to me.
But to him it's so clear.
It's a language.
It's like,
well,
quite simply you have to move this and
this becomes x equals y equals two.
We are the retards to that kid.
Hmm.
You know,
maybe like maybe like,
you know,
people with down syndrome,
they feel bad when people
don't have down syndrome.
Maybe he's just like us and we feel bad
with people who have autism cause poor
kid's got autism,
man,
he can't engage in all the normal
emotional things that we do.
Meanwhile,
this mother fuckers,
you know,
count counting to a billion in his head
while he's talking to you about how a
television is conduct constructed.
You know,
maybe we're recharged to them.
Maybe,
you know,
they look at us and I go,
this is poor fox.
They can't even do math in their head.
They don't,
they can't see through walls that
they can't read people's minds,
you know?
Well,
but some people would just,
I had a kid in the eighth grade,
his name is Michael Alig
rather Sicilian kit.
You get been fresh off the boat in the
fucking sixth grade by the eighth grade.
This motherfucker spoke three languages.
The upper know that's a silly and ship.
He picked up Spanish and he picked up
English and I used to just sit and look at
him off.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like he was such a cool motherfucker
that I just wanted to hang with him.
He was so,
and he was a married,
we used to play when you,
when we used to play hockey,
we hit them in the Chins with the,
with the hockey stick and he goes,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I would die.
He was never progressed
to the bag when my dog,
Michael Allen Bradley.
But this kid
knew nothing when we came off a
boat January in the sixth grade,
but the eighth grade knew
three fucking language.
He would talk to me in Spanish,
talk to you in English
like nothing and get A's.
You know,
some people's work ethic too.
Some people just,
they have this insane work ethic and
people would get a chance to come to
America.
It's so much different
than being born in America.
We don't have any fucking idea.
You live,
you know,
you're living in fucking
Guatemala or some shit.
You know,
your,
your opportunities are
fucking few and far between.
You know,
you live in some place
that's impoverished you for,
you're kind of fucked man.
But when you're in America,
dude,
Holy Shit.
So these guys,
and you know,
their family gets them together.
Look,
we're going to move to America,
went to have a better life and you
realize you're leaving everything behind.
You're putting all your fucking ship
and cargo planes and you're all sitting
together,
crammed in,
coach and you know,
eating fruit out of your mom's purse
and just hoping that when you get there
things are going to be better
and you don't know anybody there.
And how scary is this?
So when those motherfuckers get to school,
they come out guns blazing.
You know,
they appreciate the fact that Holy Shit,
I used to live in Italy.
Now here I am in the land of the free,
the home of the brave.
You know,
I'm in America and I'm in school and I'm
learning English and I'm just going to
go fucking crazy over here.
They're just so happy and she'll be open.
That's the one half of it because
I didn't to leave Cuba corner.
We moved to,
I woke up on 89th street
in Riverside drive.
I had all the fucking things
that a rich kid would have,
rite aid and here I was walking around
this fucking city but I didn't know
English and all you want to do when your
heart is just fit in and you have no
idea this is not trying to fit in when
you were in grammar school and you should
get a tattoo,
a long hair,
all you want to know is for them not to
know that you came from somewhere else.
I can't describe it to you.
I can't even fucking start to tell you
like sometimes I have this anger at me
and it's because I was so lucky.
We were so lucky.
I think if three of us could have been
born one of those black kids and fucking
Haiti would flies on you.
I need three of us and we have so many
fucking opportunities and sometimes I
wake up in the morning
and this really hits me.
Sometimes I go home and fucking lucky
am I that my mother came here and here I
am sitting here smoking dope.
I got to go mug somebody.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
think about,
that's what an immigrant was like.
I'm telling him for a long time I've
been writing this thing and that's how it
starts with,
you know,
I don't remember anything.
I don't remember the plane ride from Cube.
I remember nothing.
All I remember is crossing the fucking
street on 89th and Broadway up to
[inaudible] 66 and thinking to myself,
finally,
I'm going to be a fucking American.
What does that mean?
Looking at that flag,
really believe in something dog.
It's not just a piece of fucking
rag looking at that flag and going,
what the fuck?
Like looking at the wind
blowing that flag and going,
what the fuck that flag is the
answer to all my fucking problem.
That's the answer right there.
But even at that age,
I knew my mother was fucking crazy,
so I do.
I wasn't a full fledged American,
but looking at that flag,
when you look at that flag and you just
come here that they have a scene in the
beginning of Scarface when they were on
the boat and they finally see land and
they show the American
flag and the director,
whoever the guy is
brilliant enough to show,
he showed it from a different angle.
What that flag it looks like.
It's not just we overlooked
that flag every fucking day.
We overlooked that flag.
You don't know what it is to look at
that flag when you first come here and to
know that that's your fucking,
that's you're a magic carpet.
It's the highest ideal in the world.
It's the highest ideal.
That's why it's so infuriating when
politicians are fucking corrupt.
That's why it's so,
you know.
People say,
why do you criticize what
America does overseas?
Don't you love America?
Yeah.
If you love it,
you want to tell the fucking
truth about what it's doing.
You know?
If you love it,
you're supposed to stand up and go,
what the fuck is going on?
It's like you don't love it by letting
it get away with stupid shit because
there's some corrupt content.
The wheel that's not,
it doesn't mean you don't
love the idea of America.
I fucking love the idea
of America for sure.
I'm always remember we only
see the one side of that flag.
We never see both sides
together gentlemen,
and that's a point we never,
we only see that one side
of the flag right now.
You've discussed at the CIA
is setting up things in Libya.
What are they setting up?
Let's start.
No War,
let's start in business.
They're getting things going.
That's the other side of that
flag that were never able to see.
We always see once you put a mirror
on the other side of the flag,
you know what I'm saying?
That's the one side of
the flag that we have.
Since we accept this side of the flag,
we got to accept that.
So the only way that side this side is
possible where it's easy to drive around
as if they're doing all this creepy shit.
You got to break.
Unless we bring the whole world together
in on everything and that's just not
going to happen and we've
done creepy fucking shit.
They're going to do
creepy shit to trust them.
You know,
we,
you can't trust people to be cool.
You know,
the look,
the natural instinct,
if someone can get into a
position of power is to be Kadafi.
That's the natural instinct.
That natural instinct is to get botox.
When you're 80 you have this
big stupid looking rubber face,
wear goofy clothes and
just be running shit.
Even though you're this old con,
you know,
living in some fucking castle
with billions of dollars.
He doing that.
Joe,
can you tell me why is he doing it?
Maybe we put that billions
of dollars for money.
That other side of that flag is money.
Joe Rogan,
that's a lot of people
never had comprehend,
but that's the reality of it.
Standup is a beautiful thing to do.
Yeah.
Some guys are brilliant and
some guys aren't brilliant.
A millionaires.
The other fall between the crack,
the other side of the standup,
it's a business.
Yeah.
It really is a fucking business guys.
And it's like anything else.
The other side of that
flag is a business guys,
and the same way we want social
security one was 65 a country.
I said,
dude,
sell a couple kilos every once in a
while to replenish those fucking phones.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's a side of the American public.
Don't want to know.
That's the side that included Kennedy.
That's aside the Alex Jones talks
about whether it's true or not,
that's a side we not supposed to see
what's supposed to be focused on the other
side on what that machine
is supposed to mean to us.
And for guys like you and I,
I like looking behind the curtain,
but I don't,
I don't because I grew up in a,
in a corrupt hometown and I seen
what politics is at a minute level.
I can't even dream of what it is
and and national fucking level.
When,
uh,
I'm taking political contributions but
I'm going to pass your fucking bills so
you could pass that law.
That will make people's hands grow back,
but they're also going to give
him cancer when the eyeballs,
that's part of it.
It grows.
When I grew up in it,
when it was in the micro process,
now it's in the national
level of corruption isn't a
macro process and it starts
with little things and townships where
if it's a macro smaller than my micro
macro,
I'm a little high.
I'm sorry guys,
but you understand my pill.
Exactly what you're saying.
It's a,
it's very interesting.
Corruption.
If not checked grows.
It all just keeps getting bigger.
It's not like they go,
hey,
we got to cut the shit.
I know we've been making millions
of dollars on the sneak tip,
but everybody's got to stop
right now and I'm not kidding.
Why are you still making money?
These wiki leak things are
pretty cool for the country.
I think that's why these assholes
want to put that guy in jail.
They want to say compromises Americans.
No,
it doesn't.
He,
he did exactly what the New
York Times was supposed to do.
If they got that information.
They should have done
that on Twitter though.
Can you imagine if there was just like
this Twitter address that everyone
followed that tweet later.
By the way,
JFK,
here's pictures of JFK selling cocaine
to Wiki leaks has a Twitter and they were
doing they really shit on the Twitter.
They released a,
some uh,
an artist,
an article
about how um,
different,
uh,
parts of the American
economy are influenced by
genetically modified foods and
how we're trying to force
them on other countries.
And then where you're like
fucking with other countries,
if they don't go into the
genetically modified food,
if they don't start
growing like Monsanto corn,
shit like that,
you know,
those,
that,
that those,
these giant companies are way too
embedded into the political system.
They're not doing stuff for the greater
good of people there doing stuff for the
profitability of giant corporations that
moved him into position in the first
place.
The whole thing has been corrupted.
Like to sit down and pretend that that,
that,
that it's real.
It's insulting.
It's like,
it's like a stupid argument.
It's like people argue
about pro wrestling,
you know,
it's like,
what are you arguing about?
This is a fake nonsense process.
If you can't notice that from Obama,
Obama is going to pull
all the troop out of Ikea.
Oh,
he's not.
Bama won the Nobel Peace Prize and then
he sent 30,000 more fucking troops to
Afghanistan.
I mean,
come on man.
Look at all the shit that he's done
to allow these cons to get away with
stealing all that fucking
money in that bailout.
I watched that inside job movie,
Dude.
That shit is disgusting.
It's disgusting.
How deep the corruption is.
The financial,
uh,
the,
the whole financial sector.
It's scary,
dude.
They have the people that are regulators
eventually get jobs with the banks.
Like how the fuck you're telling me you
work as a guy who's working for the SEC
and you're looking into banks and
corruption and shit like that.
And then when you quit,
you get a job with the bank.
How the fuck are you not in jail?
You were the one responsible for looking
over these motherfuckers while they
were doing all sorts of crazy shit,
betting on things failing and betting
three times more than that a business is
worth and specular lives and and and,
and bedding.
Again,
fucking forcing clients to buy
shit they knew wasn't good.
Like they did a lot of crazy
creepy shit and got away with it.
I'm the only one who got
popped is that Bernie Madoff,
those mother fuckers
should all be in jail.
This should be amass
jailing and they're not.
They're not jailing anybody then
it's bullshit then it's all bullshit.
It's all bullshit that they're not you.
You gotta like hold them the the most
accountable you can and it's barely at all
people's dreams,
people's dreams.
When you steal people's dreams,
that's the worst thing
in the fucking world.
You're 63 years old also.
Somebody calls you and says,
you're not going to get you your money
at 66 or 67 all that money you put away.
That happens.
Those guys a lot too.
It's happened to a lot of fucking people.
People at six,
I just watched something
about a month ago,
people 71 getting part time
fucking jobs now the 69
can movie showed.
Um,
I believe it was Iceland.
How they went in and Jack the Icelandic
economy and like a couple of years these
banks went in and just fucking did is
created baubles and started making crazy
money,
spending an access and then it
all failed and people are fucked.
They had like the most stable,
the most,
a normalized economy.
Like it was a beautiful economy.
Everything was running smooth people.
We're hard workers.
People got shit done.
They lived a life of relative prosperity.
Now that fucked everybody lost everything.
Everyone's fucked.
Do you think that the states,
I think it already has,
every has,
what does this bailout?
What did,
what is this?
How do you,
how did these people get money when,
when their banks failed,
they,
they will,
they have bonuses in
their contract bonuses.
How the fuck do you get a bonus when the
bank feels like the idea that you have
to respect them and that they can't lose?
That's just [inaudible].
It's so cool.
Ropy the size,
the bonuses,
millions and millions of dollars,
and this is from banks.
What we would check to pay them.
We gave them money and
they're giving out money.
Either way.
If your bank fucking failed,
you can't get a bonus.
You can't get a bonus.
I'm certainly as big bank fucking failed.
Do you take no pump
personal responsibility?
Like who takes responsibility?
Somebody and it you shouldn't it be
the guy that stands to make a bonus?
If the bank does well,
that should be the guy who
takes personal responsibility.
So when the bank fucking fails,
you don't get your bonus comp face.
It's it.
It's that simple.
Why?
Why the fuck he had the president say
that is the studies like we're going to,
you know,
low limited to half of million dollars,
half a million fucking dollars
for a bonus when your bank fails,
what do you want?
These motherfuckers are so not living
in reality in most people's reality,
these cons costs so many fucking people.
Their life savings and they have to
get their bonuses and the president was
like,
Whoa,
we have to give them to them.
What the fuck are you talking about?
You have to give it to them.
You can't just step in.
They'll cut the shit.
Are you fucking crazy?
No.
You can't get $30 million
after your fucking bank fails.
No.
In the middle of a crazy down to
economy where billions of dollars from
taxpayers while he'd been funneled
to fucking banks to keep them afloat.
No,
you can't get a bonus fuck head.
You're lucky you have a job.
You're lucky.
Your head is attached to your fucking
shoulder.
Not Get a 90 fucking years.
Yeah,
you lucky you're not in
jail forever in Haiti.
Have you followed what's going
on in the city of Bell Bell?
Bell Bell.
California is a city that the
fucking guys just jacked him.
What happened like the fuck you got to
get up early in the water for this cause
they talking about like Ktc la.
It's a city here of bell off the six
Oh five or something and all the man,
everybody,
it was as corrupt as can be.
They have been jack in millions,
so if it's at that city of Bell,
if the corruption is that the cops
will have any ticket contests.
Really?
Oh this is everyday on the news.
They come up with more shit.
The guy just got reinvited.
This is old school jerseys.
Schilling school.
Here's Bell Bell,
California.
It's I think like
30 minutes from here,
30 45 minutes.
But they just been having this shit
and then lately it's a shitstorm.
They all go,
they will all steel it.
All five guys were stealing big bulls.
Understand how they feel like no one's
going to get caught fucking trail.
Remember Goodfellas and Robert De Niro
how to start killing people because
they're spending too much money.
That's the same goddamn thing.
Man.
That was a great scene,
wasn't it?
When you realized the guy came in,
his wife had a fucking
beautiful fur coat on.
It's like what the fuck are you doing?
And then they did.
They know they have to
kill this guy and then the,
it's photos of him and
his wife shot in the car.
What a great God damn movie that was on
the other night and I walked in the part
with them at the mother's house
and then borrowing the knife.
But you got to think of that whole scene
that Barbara had a knife to stab this
guy in the car.
Me One while they're eating the guys
in the trunk of the fucking car and
everything.
Like it's the 4th of July there.
Eat the eggs and bread and fucking telling
stories and remember the paint thing.
Then one for me that is such a
sick fucking movie right there.
Right moving.
What do you want from me?
There's not that many of those.
There's very few of those
that ever get that good.
You know,
it was very few movies
that ever like hit that.
That's like a perfect movie.
Goodfellas is like a
perfect fucking movie.
Everything about it,
especially when you see it 20 years later
when she was screaming at Ray Liotta
and he runs,
he starts laughing and runs away
cause gacked out of his fucking mind.
She's screaming at him and he's laughing
and when they were were packaging up
the coke and his girlfriend
was getting pissed off,
you know,
she's,
cause he's got to just fucking
making coke for him now.
And he was banging her on the side
still with his wife and he's got her
packaging coke form and then you know,
he,
he leaves laughing and she fucking
throws the coke at the door.
You remember that shit is the craziest
thing ever is the craziest thing ever
when he gets to that scene.
And I did coke for 30 years,
when he gets to that scene and he snorts
and he pops his head up and his eyes
dilate right in front of the
camera that seen as well.
I turn the movie off.
Really?
It bothers me to go.
And you know what bothers me
because he steals it though.
He taps into the coach when he's
standing there with his arms.
Watch it again when she's weighing it
and he's standing there with his arms
folded.
Let me tell you,
you see him with my honors float.
That means your potential energy,
you're ready to explode.
You can't even take watching that.
Fill that bucket.
Then below what he sees,
the fucking that helicopter
and you know it's behind you.
That chitter chatter they have.
That's paranoid talk.
Why can't we go to your mother's house
when they dropped the guns off and you
imagine Joe,
what can we go to your mother's
house and drop off guns?
They had this Cheddar chive when he
gets out of jail and he's famous for the
coke and he comes home and he's trying
to tell her that he wanted for money.
He wants to get high.
I been there,
Cara.
Karen,
what'd you do?
It was what we saw.
We had care and that whole chitter chatter
looking how high he just passes out
and just pass up.
Perfect.
Yeah.
They just pass out from
the [inaudible] side.
That's all.
We had.
$60,000 no fucking thing
he had in the ceiling.
What?
The cops rating the founder.
Great fucking movie,
but it's amazing when he's looking up
at the helicopters and he's so fucking
yes.
When he uses the car and
he thought it was over it.
He's getting rid of guns,
right?
Wasn't he?
Yeah.
You have no idea what it is to get coked
up in this little room and look out
that window by the blonde.
That's like,
there'll be a,
what do you call those things?
A fire hydrant,
but in your mind it becomes a dog.
Could you imagine if you've got
like Osama bin Ladin coked up.
Could you imagine if you've got someone,
someone like Gadhafi coked up right now,
how paranoid he would be.
I think just how it's done.
Is it you think he does calorie?
If of course you're a fucking terrorist,
you're probably fucking
fucking hookers looking.
Coffee's not a terrorist.
He's a,
he's a dictator.
I mean,
I mean there's some he's,
but I mean,
yeah,
he's the same thing.
It was a bad,
bad person.
Enemy,
That was a guy called Carlos,
something that was part of the middle
cartel in the 80s bad motherfucker.
The one that was in charge
of bring it up all the blow.
He got so crazy.
I'm not in a dear call.
Lowe's.
Yeah.
What's his last name?
He resonate dear cause Nicola.
Yeah.
He was the one that,
that the blow up,
I might've made that up blow was the
guy in the island that he went to visit
Johnny Depp,
the guy with the blue eyes.
We had the machine guns
and shit with this guy.
His name is Carlo,
laid their cold calls a day.
Dad got his sentence reduced.
He got like 900 years
knocked off his sentence.
He still got four Pete hundred more to do.
He's the one that went from
the government and said,
dawn,
I gave for adult envelopes
face to face bow and uh,
Carlos,
they dead.
How they nailed him was he was actually
getting cameras like Ryan does,
sending them around the room.
He'd get a plate below.
He'd sit there and lick it with a towel
on and just do bumps and every once in a
while he'd go like this or chicken
coming to suck his dick get smacked.
He'd do more blow.
Just tell poetry all day.
And finally they got the mentally cartel
got their hands on this and they were
like,
this can't happen.
Get Bullshit on the phone.
Bush,
we've got something for you.
Right.
I'll tell you exactly where he is.
We're going to email to take it.
Really fundamentally
cartel gave him up real.
Exactly.
Yeah,
because they couldn't take that.
This guy was folded and he's
making videos of himself naked,
sweating with his eyes.
This big blow for 24 hours pops.
Fuck Charlie Sheen.
This guy was naked doing bumps and,
and you know saying him
talking about La Luna,
you know,
stars and the mountains and then he
would go online and check would come and
suck his dick and he was like,
shoot her,
shoot her on tape.
And they just keep,
you see him pull the by rankles he should,
he'd be bleeding fucked and
then he'd do more blood.
And I wish I was lying to you.
This guy was killing people
and tape doing blogs.
Just sweat,
not eating for days.
Brilliant Shit.
And then they stick.
One of the million cartel
got this and they're like,
we can't have this.
They went and got him
and brought him back.
They still have those pictures of him
on the plane next to a marine and he's
just looking around like,
what the fuck do I do?
He looks back and you turned them in.
Holy Shit.
Did you see you saw cocaine cowboys,
right?
Yeah.
No.
That woman,
what's her name is Zelda?
Zelda.
She's out.
She's back in Columbia,
man.
They got pictures of her in Columbia
at the airport hanging out free.
And this,
this is the movie,
just detail after detail how
many people she had killed.
Wow.
That bitch,
the Godmother,
I think they call their Griselda.
She made so much money,
hundreds and hundreds of millions
of dollars and Koch money,
man,
she was killing people left and right.
They got this guy who's her hit man who's
in jail and they interview him in jail
and he's just telling them all the
different times Griselda have made me kill
this guy.
So I had to go do some business
and that killed this guy,
how to do some business.
And I said,
I wouldn't do that because they wanted
me to do a drive by and there was a baby
in the car
like,
whoa.
It was fucking Colombians.
They used to shoot anything.
There's a picture of you
go on Daily News archives.
1984 a Columbian family in
Brooklyn got slaughtered.
Well,
the room for the wake was 14
bodies and there was 12 kids.
Oh my.
They sat the kids down who the 12 and
put bullets in and they're fucking
forehead.
Oh my God.
The pictures just,
they don't show the bodies,
but they show the funeral parlor
and just the row of fucking body.
It's just come on beans and over nothing.
This isn't the 80s when they were shooting
you over $2 just to make that point,
you know you always fucking
money was going to shoot you.
That was the big thing about them,
right?
The Colombians were always taught to
be the most like Colombian neckties.
They'd go for fucking throw down,
pull your tongue out.
They wanted,
they wanted an intimidation at the
maximum under the fucking savages,
and that's right next door to us,
buddy.
That's,
that's just like what's going on in
Mexico that's happening right now.
But in a bigger,
even bigger scale,
you know,
because the Colombians,
even though they had like they were
selling drugs and they were bringing drugs
and they weren't getting that much
resistance from their government.
You know what I mean?
There's Kinda correct.
It was part of their,
actually,
yeah,
it was kind of corrupt.
But in Mexico it's not the same man.
Mexico,
they get a lot of resistance,
but it doesn't matter.
Still was doing it.
They're still doing it.
So it's scarier because it's
more like it's more militaristic,
you know,
action in Spanish.
[inaudible] below more or Blanca.
That's the Bro.
That's a silver fish.
That's a finished from the rubber guard.
The Lomo or blind log this call,
either bullets or money.
Which one do they just
show up and which ones?
Bullets.
A global plumber is bullets.
Yeah.
Blanca is a lot of times cash.
So plot that they just
show up at your house,
but a gun down when an envelope,
a little more block that
she would get a new rap song
and your bitch,
that's how they were corrupt.
Colombo,
poor fucking girl who was a member.
That girl was trying
to be a sheriff and uh,
some town in near Juarez,
remember that shit?
She was 20 years old.
There's a big story because
this is college girl decides
she's going to fucking
get a job as a sheriff and tried
to clean up the town within months.
This poor girl is trying
to seek asylum in America.
They're trying to kill her,
although slice your fucking throat,
you know,
you're either in or you're out because
you know there's no coming back.
There's no,
no,
no.
That's a different society.
This isn't the terrifying man.
This isn't,
it's terrifying shit.
You know,
it's terrifying.
It's terrifying that we are
not doing anything about it.
But yet we were fucking around in Libya,
April one,
1984.
December 12th of 1984,
I was minding my business,
or 83,
I was minding my business
is Snowmass village.
I didn't know nothing about nothing.
Let was just snorting coke and going to
school at [inaudible] and he just had an
electrician's job and I heard this boom,
boom.
But I didn't know what happened.
I just went to bed the next day,
they were telling me a story about this
drug dealer named Steven Gray Buck.
He got in a fucking car with the
started up and they put a bomb under his
fucking car.
They asked me to Colorado,
tell him some white dude,
and I asked her rather than the papers,
he was about to go on
trial for tax evasion,
Jewish guy that was in with the Columbia.